entre rage et désespoir entre
revendication est remise en cause qui
n'ont jamais été aussi nombreuses le
salon de l'agriculture
et cette année vous l'avez tous constaté
évidemment un lieu sous haute tension
est notre invité le sait mieux que
personne pour soir xavier beulin chèvre
est en dedans de la fnsea merci d'être
avec nous à ce rendez vous donc sur le
salon de public sénat avec l' agence
france-presse
vous répondrez comme chaque semaine aux
trois grandes questions de l'émission
première question on l'a vu on le voit
d'ailleurs encore au moment où nous
parlons marine le pen échappe depuis ce
matin ici a tout tué les a accueilli
avec une certaine bienveillance par le
monde agricole alors est ce que ça vous
a folle deuxième question quelques
heures après la fin des négociations
commerciales c'était c'était à minuit
l'heure du crime diront peut-être les
producteurs est ce qu'il y a toujours
cette victoire du pot de fer c'est à
dire la grande distribution sur le pot
de terre vous le dirai tout à l'heure à
un chao de l' agence france-presse
et puis enfin troisième partie de
l'émission troisième partie de preuve
par trois eh bien ce sera accusé xavier
beulin défendez vous répondez à vos
détracteurs ils sont nombreux car on les
attend on les entend nombreux également
depuis le début du salon 1 2 jean luc
mélenchon à d'autres responsables
politiques et puis pivot rivaux
syndicaux également qui vous tiennent
vous comme premier responsable de ce qui
arrive aujourd'hui à l'agriculture
française à leur première question
xavier beulin
parmi vos spécialités ici pendant le
salon c'est l'accueil des personnalités
politiques évidemment un
il ya eu le chef de l'état de mayorat
nicolas sarkozy aujourd'hui parmi les
responsables politiques marine le pen
vous êtes allés l'accueillir
non non et j'attends d'ailleurs qu'elles
viennent nous rendre visite sur le sens
de l'effet soit parce que c'est le lieu
on peut discuter
je dois dire qu'avec marine le pen les
relations sont pas simples d'abord parce
qu'elle m'accuse régulièrement sans
vraiment d'ailleurs se plonger sur les
questions de fond ce que je regrette
et vous avez vu vous accuse elle aussi
oui je peux aussi me tenir des propos
finalement qui vont dans le sens du poil
qui rassure qui je crois qu'aujourd'hui
endroit là on doit la vérité on la doit
aux éleveurs on la doit aux agriculteurs
on la doit aussi aux consommateurs et
aux citoyens
on est dans une situation très difficile
avec des marchés mondiaux qui sont quand
même plus tôt avait avant d'entrer dans
le temps long ça va des dossiers il ya
quand même la question de marine le pen
vous me dites vous vous n'êtes pas allés
l'accueillir donc c'est un choix
délibéré de votre part vous dites mais
elle vient pas nous voir mais vous non
plus vous n'avez pas les couilles
ailleurs et cela il va accueillir les
membres
d'abord de l'exécutif le chef de l'état
leroy ministre le ministre de la culture
ça va de soi bien sûr on n'a pas à
accueillir non plus toutes les
personnalités qui passe sur le salon
c'est nous qui aujourd'hui sommes en
situation de recevoir les personnalités
je dois d'ailleurs dire qu'à la fnsea on
a proposé onze questions à toutes les
personnalités politiques qui vont passer
et on leur demande de pouvoir répondre à
ces questions alors je le disais une
certaine bienveillance quand même hein
vous l'avez constaté vous allez sans
doute pouvoir le déplorer dans un
instant pour la présidente du front
national on l'écouté elle a tenu ces
propos tout à l'heure lors de sa visite
aujourd'hui la situation est une
situation catastrophique on le dit
chaque année mais l'urgence est
maintenant les mesures qui auraient dû
être prises il ya deux ans ne l'ont ne
n'ont pas été prises aujourd'hui on
parle encore de négociations
on essaye de faire de cette crise un
problème franco français c'est pas un
problème franco français
il faut faire le bras de fer avec
bruxelles maintenant stop c'est terminé
moi je crois que pour sauver la peau des
éleveurs français
il faut avoir la peau de phil hogan le
commissaire européen à l'agriculture
c'est très clair parce que cet homme là
c'est l'homme qui défend toutes les
mesures qui sont en train de tuer
l'agriculture française
alors marine le pen fidèle à son
discours haro sur l'europe d'appro du
commissaire alors qu'en pensez vous ça
va très loin comment est-ce que pensez
vous de cette demande de démission du
commissaire aux robes d'abord je suis
heureux que marine le pen parle d'europe
c'est rare non l on parle souvent non
elle est souvent la folie oui pour la
faute ou pour sortir de leur abri
là elle dit finalement les problèmes que
nous avons en france ils viennent de
l'europe
ce sur quoi je suis d'accord c'est vrai
en gare immigrantes caci des problèmes
aujourd'hui embargo sur la démission de
phil hogan
non attendez enfin après bon moi ça me
regarde plus on a aujourd'hui des
institutions est-ce qu'on veut m
la cabane sur le chien comme on dit chez
moi est-ce qu'on veut aussi travailler
et faire progresser un certain nombre de
posture moi ce que je demande
aujourd'hui à phil hogan ces deux choses
d'abord qu'il sorte de sa posture
libéral mais ça c'est impossible
peut-être que la solution c'est de
changer de commissaire a forcément
impossible c'est aussi à juncker de
faire le boulot
il ya un président de demander de renier
ses patrons et ne renie et aussitôt nord
de l'europe aujourd'hui shell grossiord
il s'agit de comprendre et d'accepter un
fait qui est que l'agriculture ne peut
pas être traité comme un autre secteur
économique parce qu'on travaille avec du
vivant
on travaille des impondérables s'appelle
le climat qui s'appelle l'évolution sur
les marchés
ça ça doit être prise en compte or la
pac actuelle il est vrai ne répond plus
à ses situations de crise donc il faut
restaurer un certain nombre de
mécanismes mais par ailleurs il faut
aussi qu avec nos collègues européens
nous faisions convergence je demande au
succès aujourd'hui au chef de l'état de
bien prendre en compte la situation des
cols la france est la première puissance
agricole européenne
est ce que le chef de l'état aujourd'hui
a les moyens à la conviction de m au
même titre que le break site
peut-être même que la question des
réfugiés même si je suis prudent sur ce
sujet là la question agricole au même
niveau pour le dire autrement
est ce que la voix de la france
aujourd'hui peut-être entendu c'est ça
notre sujet
à partir de là je pense qu avec madame
merkel avec un certain nombre d'autres
dirigeants
la commission se tenir a quand même aux
demandes des états membres alors je vous
apprends voyons pas systématiquement
toutes les responsabilités à la
commission bac si les états membres ne
sont pas convaincus eux mêmes ne nous
étonnons pas que la vainqueur donc
attendre a envoyé la balle de 2 sur le
gouvernement français ben c'est ce qu'a
fait également aujourd'hui bruno le
maire un qui était ministre de
l'agriculture qui connaît bien le
secteur il a d'ailleurs décidé de passer
trois jours pleins sur le salon cette
année
on l'écouté je vois un certain
parallélisme dans vos propos ah je pense
qu'il faut remettre en question la
politique agricole commune par la
direction qu'elle a choisi aujourd'hui
et je voudrais que la france en fasse
une priorité aussi importante que la
question des réfugiés aujourd'hui du
contrôle des frontières
parce que c'est l'avenir de nos paysans
qui est en jeu et je voudrais que la
france tape du poing sur la table
au niveau du président de la république
à qui j'ai écrit je lui demandé de le
faire
en rassemblant tous les chefs d'état et
en dix ans la direction actuelle de la
politique agricole commune nous emmène
tous dans le mur
parce que vous êtes en train de
supprimer tous les instruments
d'intervention tous les instants
régulation vous êtes en train d'aller
vers une libéralisation totale qui va
aboutir à la fermeture de dizaines de
milliers d'exploitations en europe
c'est à la france de taper du poing sur
la table pour réclamer cette régulation
et c'est l'enjeu le plus important
aujourd'hui pour nos agriculteurs
alors vous avez qu'allez-vous discours
c'est ce que vous dites est un bras de
fer aujourd'hui bien sûr entre la france
et l'europe et que la france n'est que
faiblesse alors je rajoute quand même un
argument aux propos de bruno le maire
que je partage je le dis très clairement
quand je discute aujourd'hui avec les
dirigeants allemands qu'ils soient
politiques qu'ils soient syndicaux
j'entends à peu près la même réponse
laissons mourir les plus faibles et ça
fera de la place pour les autres ça
n'est pas acceptable
les plus faibles aujourd'hui ça voudrait
dire qu'en france on abandonne en
moyenne la tranche 25 40 ans les gens
qui viennent d'investir qui sont pleines
capacités de pouvoir produire et
d'assurer l'agriculture de demain c'est
pas acceptable comme propos donc quand
on évoque la régulation quand on évoque
la crise
oui il faut aujourd'hui les instruments
au niveau communautaire et corps et donc
il faut peser à bruxelles mais je vais
quand même sur l'accueil qu'a reçu ici
marine le pen est ce que ça vous a folle
puisque c'était la question de cette
première partie transport 3g pas
s'affoler mais ce que je veux quand même
que mes collègues comprennent c'est que
on peut se contenter comme ça d'un
discours un peu facile
un peu démago quand même disons le on
doit aussi analyser l'ensemble
l'ensemble des sujets et je note quand
même que pour beaucoup d'agriculteurs
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont très très
majoritaire chacun a conscience que si
l'agriculture française aujourd'hui est
arrivé à ce niveau de performance elle
le doit aussi à la construction
européenne
ce que nous avons à faire c'est beaucoup
plus que dénoncer que de faire en sorte
que les fissures aujourd'hui qui
pourrait apparaître dans la construction
européenne
ne cesse de s'élargir
moi je préfère travailler à la
convergence européenne qui a des formes
de divergences et surtout à des formes
d'opposition
je voudrais dire d'ailleurs qu'à ce
propos la en particulier sur le plan
social sur un certain nombre de normes
environnementales
oui aujourd'hui il ya des distorsions
d'un pays à l'autre qu'attendent les
institutions communautaires pour nous
rapprocher en sorte que ce marché unique
puisque en viandes nos adhérents
beaucoup de personnes du monde agricole
parce qu'il s'était ses discours de la
démagogie c'est celui de marine le pen
vous mais ils sont différents ils sont à
bout quand aujourd'hui vous perdez 3 à
4000 euros par semaine quand vous êtes
producteur de porcs ne vous étonnez pas
que les discours un peu facile puisse
être évidemment des discours de
réassurance est-ce que ça construit pour
autant je suis pas sûr moi je suis en
train de me battre en ce moment pour
mettre sur pied un fonds à destination
des producteurs de porcs payé par la
grande distribution qui aujourd'hui se
fait quand même sans jeu de mots
beaucoup de gras sur le dos des paysans
se font on va le mettre en place ou non
c'est pas la panacée mais ça va
permettre pendant quelques mois de
ramener la trésorerie de ramener un
point michel aux effets du concret je
suis pas en train de faire de l'
encontre de l'incantation sur ces sujets
là d'accord à propos du ministre de
l'agriculture
il passe des mauvais quart d'heure ici
clairement il est il est copieusement
hué il a été sifflé tout à l'heure aux
questions au gouvernement à l'assemblée
nationale
on peut poser la question des forces et
des faiblesses peut-être surtout de
votre ministre de l'agriculture je pars
peut-être une question et à marine le
pen est ce qu'il faut demander sa
démission quand on est dans votre genre
de série sont déjà prononcés je suis
républicain je suis démocrate il ya un
gouvernement au travail avec les
ministres en poste
ce que je peux noter quand même c'est
que ya probablement chemise l'inculture
une difficulté de forme en particulier à
il est le dire mais il est porte parole
du gouvernement
il prend la parole huit fois sur dix
pour parler de tas de sujets qui n'ont
rien à voir entre cultures l'agriculteur
lui en face derrière son écran derrière
son son poste de radio
il entend quoi il entend son ministre
parler de tas de sujets ne pas parler
d'agriculture
il faut bien comprendre que ça forcément
ça est forcément des impacts peut-être
que l'erreur du présent dans le public
ça a été de confirmer dans ce rôle de
porte parole
peut-être aurait-il fallu qu
définitivement on le nomme ministre de
la culture et repasser votre souhait
votre femme votre revendication la
seconde revendication parce qu'on lui
enlever une casquette d'abord on a
besoin d'un ministre à plein temps et
quand on a besoin d'un ministre qui soit
mieux et plus présents à bruxelles
il l'est depuis quelques semaines parce
que ça chauffe peut-être insuffisamment
auparavant je lui dis aussi attention il
suffit pas d'aller à bruxelles
il faut faire aujourd'hui alliance est
recherché et les majorités au sein des
états membres pour porter aussi nos
falardeau dit il suffit pas d'elle à
bruxelles on lui a fait le procès
également à stéphane le foll de ne pas
aller suffisamment au conseil européen à
l'agriculture
oui je lui ai adressé vous aussi on sera
d'ailleurs j'ignorais ce seront les ans
je l'ignorais non vraiment je suis
sincère mais mais le conseil des miss
est une chose la construction d'une
pensée d'une au fond d'une réaction est
au niveau de la crise européenne c'en
est une autre
et ça ça se construit je fais en ce
moment ce moment même mois la tournée
des capitales pour aller voir mes
collègues mes homologues et leur dire
voilà est-ce qu'on peut se mettre
d'accord sur une feuille de route
comment est-ce qu'on régule demain en
laye en porc et quel type de mesures de
gestion prises on peut mettre en place
ça se construit tout ça on peut pas une
fois par mois est à russell et dire
voilà ce que je pense voilà ce qu'il
faudrait
non
il faut construire vous avez dit tout à
l'heure que vous réclamez un ministre à
temps plein en quelque sorte vous avez
l'occasion de dire directement au chef
de l'état lors de l'inauguration on sait
que ce qu'est ce qui vous a répondu on
est reçu en est on discute et on nous
dit ça au chef de l'état il vous entend
et il prend ses responsabilités moi je
discutais commises sur la culture je
discute aussi commises l'économie des
finances
je discute à khemis travail parce qu'on
a des sujets qui nous sont évidemment
très propre en matière à l'école on a
beaucoup de saisonniers en agriculture
on les traite pas forcément bien dans
les différents projets de loi la loi sur
la pénibilité par exemple la loi sur la
complémentaire santé sur tout ça
l'agriculture est mal servi donc voilà
on fait aussi d'accueil travail de
responsables professionnels sentais un
peu délaissé d'une certaine manière si
je comprends bien tout cas bon
aujourd'hui je peux au moins dire et ça
ne frustre ap admises parce que lui-même
l'a reconnu
je pense qu'il a sous-estimé la
profondeur et la gravité de la crise
c'est seulement depuis un passé assez
récent qu'on a vraiment pris en compte
la dimension qui étaient devant nous je
rappelle que à ce même salon à ce même
plateau il ya un an
reprenez mes propos j'alerte est déjà
sur un début de crise qui était sérieux
un an après ça c'est plutôt à palanquée
découle en partie on l'a dit dans un
certain nombre de décisions de l'union
européenne ont mal été géré ses états
dans la fin des quotas laitiers
mais mais mais aussi parce que enfin
disons les choses simplement mais en
même temps très directement comment se
fait-il qu'un certain nombre de pays
aujourd'hui ne vivent pas la crise de la
même manière que nous la vivons ici
simplement parce que nous avons des
niveaux de compétitivité en france
oui qui n'ont plus rien à voir ça c'est
notre faute ça c'est notre
responsabilité pour ça que j'ai salué la
semaine dernière une des annonces du
premier ministre qui va être une baisse
de charges sociales
c'est ce que vous avez obtenus et pour
tout les admire les annonces de matignon
que vous voulez positive positiver ou et
président d'avec énervé il faut quand
même il faut reconnaître quand même ce
qui est fait
on va écouter le premier ministre parce
qu'il a été interrogé lors de sa visite
samedi et on lui a demandé
si les agriculteurs lui faisait encore
confiance face à toutes ces crises qui
s'accumulent
ils savent que à notre niveau nous
agissons déjà mais qu'il faut d'abord
que les professionnels sera organise que
les filières se réorganise
il faut agir aussi au niveau de l'europe
on nous a aussi beaucoup parlé des
négociations commerciales entre l'union
européenne et les etats unis
non moi je pense que cette confiance
doit continuer ils savent de toute façon
que ya pas de solution facile et toutes
faites et que les messages de démagogie
ne peuvent pas passer non plus voilà
donc le premier ministre y est restée au
salon vous vous lui fait toujours
confiance
la confiance elle se gagne aussi par les
décisions et surtout par le respect des
décisions prises
ce que j'attends c'est que tout ce qui a
été annoncé là depuis deux semaines se
mettent en oeuvre très très vite donc il
ya des décrets apprendre par exemple sur
la baisse des charges
il ya des décrets à prendre sur les
normes et sur la réglementation que nous
attendons si tout ça vient en temps
utile oui alors nous pourrons dire qu'il
ya une relative confiance aujourd'hui
alors avec l'exécutif
pour ajouter un propos qu'a tenus le
premier ministre il dit il faut aussi
travailler sur les filières et il a
raison là dessus on a besoin aussi de se
restructurer et de renforcer le rôle de
nos filières mais ça suppose aussi qu'on
n'est pas un double discours en france
la chance de l'agriculture française
c'est sa diversité
or qu'est ce qui se passe depuis des
années on oppose les uns et les autres
on oppose une certaine organisation qui
permet de répondre un chant très
concurrentiel quelques chants mondiale
on nous a bercés aujourd'hui on nous a
bercés par don à travers des
négociations commerciales depuis des
années dans une grande cour mondiale sur
laquelle il faut quand même donner des
coudes et jouer des coudes vrai mais en
même temps on doit aussi défendre une
agriculture qui est beaucoup plus
orienté sur des produits très segmenté à
haute valeur ajoutée secteur et on a
besoin de l'une et de l'eau de ces
cultures que l'une ou l'autre monde et
parce qu'ils se disent que les plus gros
veulent tuer finalement les noms
paysanne est justement bien c'est pas
notre intérêt c'est pas l'intérêt mais
bien sûr oui regardez sur ce ça n'aide
pas vous mais peut-être d'autres si oui
tant des fans ne jouons pas avec les
mots c'est trop sérieux
on a tout intérêt à défendre une aoc
comptez en corse ou dans le sud-ouest
comme on a aussi intérêt à mettre dans
des conditions économiques des
agriculteurs qui sont même si je viens
deux secteurs qui n'ont vraiment plus
rien avoir en fait non son retour en
terre ils sont complètement ils sont
complémentaires même s'il s'éloigne de
plus en plus je voudrais pas vous donner
un chiffre parce que moi je suis irrité
par tout ce que j'entends la
consommation en france c'est pas très
important
la consommation en france de produits
sous signe de qualité bio label aoc et
indications géographiques
c'est moins de 20 % de notre
consommation qu'est-ce qu'on fait du
reste je pose la question qu'est ce
qu'on fait du reste
alors cessons d'opposer jouant les
synergies jouant les complémentarités
mettons toutes ces agricultures en bonne
condition économique pour les pouvant
s'exercer encore une question avant
d'aborder la deuxième partie de
l'émission vous allez accueillir nicolas
sarkozy demain il sera accueilli comme
madame le pen
mami lui à 6 ans le blâme les commodités
mais pour lancer vous avez là nous
sommes ici sur un salon ouvert on
accueille tout le monde avant bien sûr
mais là vous m'aviez dit tout à l'heure
si madame les libéraux non vous n'êtes
pas allés accueillir marine le pen dans
les airs et demain avec ailleurs nicolas
ne veut pas passer sur le stand en effet
si c'est son choix
non monsieur sarkozy qui passera sur les
allées lui demander des comptes parce
que parce que c'est facile d'accuser le
pouvoir en place mais par exemple la loi
lme dont on va parler tout de suite là
hein et puis les normes
le grenelle de l'environnement grenelle
2 est également oui cdu a lancé
l'invitation à son quinquennat des
comptes avait bien sûr ah oui d'ailleurs
il se fâche souvent quand je demandais
kurz est suivie oui alors il va se
lâcher encore demain c'est possible et
c'est aussi une information flash et oui
parce que encore une fois je crois qu'il
faut être équitable
bon il ya évidemment un certain nombre
de sujets qui sont affectés à d'autres
gouvernements et en particulier son
grenelle de l'environnement ce que les
paysans ont mal vécu c'est
systématiquement depuis le grenelle
toutes les normes toutes les
réglementations ont été élaborés non pas
en concertation avec la profession
écoles mais contre la professeure recall
aura fait et ça c'est immanquable vous
renvoyez deux ados la gauche et la
droite
vous savez oui oui je suis paysan jeu
indique halliche dirigeants
professionnels donc les questions
politiques de petite politique ça ne
m'interesse qui m'intéresse
en fait c'est ce qui se pa non si on ne
vire en voilà deux ados la gauche et la
droite d'où le succès de marine le pen
on ne vit pas en tout cas de promesses
c'est tout ce qu'on peut retenir et
aujourd'hui même si un certain nombre de
dirigeants de l'opposition au beau jeu
de critiquer ce qui se passe j'espère
que dans leur programme ils seront aussi
intégrés y compris prendre en compte
peut-être des erreurs qu'il a converti
quand vous aurez recueillies sont
eux-mêmes géré pendant quelques temps
verra quand vous pourrez dépouiller tous
les questionnaires que vous suivez
soumis lors de ce salon cette année
puissent consommer les mares des visites
apéritif et dégustation a uniquement
alors quelques heures après la fin des
négociations commerciales avec la grande
distribution un ultimatum c'était
c'était cette nuit-là à minuit
y at il une victoire du pot de fer
contre le pot de terre c'est-à-dire des
grands distributeurs qui étrangle dit-on
les petits producteurs vous allez le
dire dans un instant à anne chaon de la
sp et on écoute d'abord le ministre de
l'agriculture stéphane le foll pour qui
la course à la baisse des prix du lait a
été enrayée cette nuit en écoute ce que
je sais puisque ça se termine à minuit
c'est que pour ce qui est des prix sur
le lait des engagements qui avait été
demandé par le gouvernement à la grande
distribution aux industriels de stopper
ce qu'était la course à la baisse ou
prix a été semble-t-il un engagement qui
n'est tenu on arrête cette spirale à la
baisse s'était la demande qui a été
faite ces généralités sur des
discussions d'après ce qu'on avait eu
comme information qui continuait à
mettre une pression sur les prix c'était
insensé
dans la situation actuelle et voilà and
so on est avec nous notre consoeur de là
il a l'air content ministre stéphane le
foll vous partager son soulagement
il semble même un peu optimiste moi j'ai
d'autres infos depuis minuit hier soir
puisque jusqu'à une heure du matin on a
essayé de savoir où en étaient les négos
comme on dit je note qui a des contrats
non signés à minuit hier soir qui porte
sur quoi exactement
notamment sur la production porcine
qu'est ce qui bloque
abbas qui bloque c'est évidemment
toujours cette tendance naturelle ou
depuis des années des années toute
négociation quel que soit le contexte
dans lequel nous soyons au plan
international ou européen démarre avec
des moins systématiquement
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
demandons nous intégrer dans ses
négociations commerciales à travers
notamment peut-être une révision à
nouveau
de la fameuse one mona lisa sion
d'économie on va en parler d indicateur
de coût de revient ou de coûts de
production des producteurs agricoles
aujourd'hui il faut bien voir comment ça
se passe la négociation elle se situe à
l'aval de la production écoles entre une
laiterie un industriel un abattoir un
transformateur et les enseignes de
distribution notamment sur l'aspect des
marques bon est-ce qu'à aucun moment on
prend en compte le coût de revient du
producteur jamais mais ça j'arrête un
perron péron
c'est tellement aberrant et nous sommes
le seul secteur le seul aujourd'hui où
nous acceptons en france que nous
puissions vendre à perte
c'est le seul film l'industrie
agroalimentaire se plaint énormément
aussi le président de l'ania jean
philippe girard me disais ce matin c'est
encore pire qu'en 2015
l'intimidation au bras d'ailleurs c'est
un petit clin d'oeil que je vous fait il
ya beaucoup de journalistes
d'investigation aujourd'hui et j'en sais
quelque chose
bon j'aimerais que de temps en temps
certains se faufile dans ces
négociations
ce serait très intéressant croyez venir
vous mettez nous sur la voir vous savez
ce que vous allez vivre
on va vous convoquez à 12h à 20h on va
vous faire passer mais entre temps vous
aura fait un temps dans une salle non
chauffée à peine éclairé sans rien a
déçu en ce sens rien à déjeuner sans
rien à dîner et c'est ça les
négociations on intimide les commerciaux
on est aujourd'hui dans un monde de
barbare de barbare de voyous dans les
négociations commerciales
je le dis avec beaucoup de force et ça
n'enlève rien ça n'enlève rien aux
propos que tiennent les directeurs ou
les patrons dans celle qui eux nous
disent oui je vais légales et les voyous
on les connaît alors c'est michel
edouard leclerc et c'est serge papin
c'est un sujet qui sont des voyous la
main sur le coeur ils nous disent
aujourd'hui mais tout va bien on discute
on négocie sauf que leurs commerciaux
aujourd'hui je vais reprendre les propos
de l'un d'entre eux que je ne citerai
pas la grande distribution
c'est un bordel organisé voilà ce qu'on
me dit ça veut dire quoi
et un bordel créatifs à dire qu'en gros
on a des axes on a des orientations et
après mais sur les commerciaux
débrouillez vous vous êtes payés à la
commission
vous avez bien fait votre boulot tant
mieux pour vous si c'est la fameuse elle
émeut la loi dite de modernisation
économique adopté en 2008 que organisé
en fait sentir et entre autres alors
depuis il ya eu la loi monkey à corriger
quand même s'attendre le show mais n'est
pas allée assez loin et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je le dis avec beaucoup
d'insistance
si désormais dans toutes les formes de
contraint de négociations nous
n'intégrons pas le maillon de la
production je pense que alors nous
retrouvons chaque année avec les mêmes
difficultés alors je suis une avancée
qui doit pouvoir être permise par la loi
françois hollande s'est exprimé sur
cette question il menace effectivement
de durcir la législation
si cette liberté de négociation qui a
été accordée au distributeur ou prétexte
de favoriser les consommateurs se
retourne contre les producteurs on
écoute chef de l'état cette loi avait
été votée dans le caca d'un précédent
c'est une loi qui a permis au
distributeur d'imposer ses règles
et bien maintenant dans ce que je
propose
on pourra faire afficher le prix
producteurs pour que le producteur
puisse être sûr que il va pas être la
variable d'ajustement entre l'industriel
et le distributeur et cette loi sera
votée avant l'été et je dois dire aux
distributeurs même si je ne veux pas
faire là aussi de simplification
outrancière qui dirait voilà les seuls
responsables ce sont eux faux faucilles
et de voir qu'elle est
la responsabilité de tous mais je leur
dis attention à ce que vous allez faire
dans les 48 prochaines heures
parce que ça va déterminer le contenu de
la prochaine loi voilà voilà pour cette
interview réalisée par olivier alleman
de notre de nos amis de deux campagnes
tv
si on revoit cette loi d'ici l'été comme
le propose le président et qu'on flèche
à chaque étape de la chaîne le coût de
revient
on va peut-être à lui mais aussi
l'industrie alors d'abord ce seront des
indicateurs à dire d'expert
c'est pas mon coût de revient qui va
être pris en compte vous pouvez bien le
comprendre mais en même temps par quels
moyens pouvons-nous quand même
définitivement introduire dans ces
négociations
et au fond par transparence avoir la
possibilité d'introduire quand même ce
coût de revient dans la négociation
c'est ça le sujet auquel nous sommes
confrontés aujourd'hui les éleveurs
parle de loi leclerc à propos de la lme
à l'époque vous aviez été associé aux
travaux
oui oui mais on n'a pas été entendu on
n'a pas été entendu pourquoi parce que
encore une fois il ya des intérêts
divergents et une des questions quand
même qui est posée aujourd'hui notamment
par rapport à cette guerre des prix à
laquelle se livrent les anciens qu'on le
veuille ou non c'est que nous ne sommes
plus aujourd'hui en face de plusieurs
enseignes
on est en face de quatre centrales de
destitution pape lui quatre centrales
d'achat pardon qui aujourd'hui à
l'évidence bon pèse à peu près 25% du
marché
est-ce qu'on a capacité ou non à
réintroduire une sorte de pacte de
confiance entre producteurs
transformateurs et distributeurs
enseigne de restauration hors domicile
au passage également pour faire ensemble
on retrouve quand même de l'équité dans
ces négociations alors tout à l'heure
vous demandiez à une action plus
vigoureuse des pouvoirs publics
vis-à-vis de l'europe mais c'est aussi
la demande qui est formulée dans
l'application de la loi lme par un
ancien ministre
un du quinquennat nicolas sarkozy c'est
hervé novelli qui était en charge on
s'en souvient de la consommation on
l'écouté vous pourrez réagir l'état a
failli
l'état n'a pas poursuivi les grandes
enseignes comme moi je les fais un
certain nombre de ministres n'ont pas
agi comme il l'aurait dû parce que l'un
déséquilibre c'était la capacité
qu'avait l'état a signé
les grandes réseau de distribution si
les contrats n'était pas équilibrée
je les fais et je n'ai donc pas de leçon
de recevoir sur la nécessité de
rechercher les ai encore montré les
muscles face aux distributeurs
je voudrais juste réagir je crois qu'on
vous entende il ya un peu de bruit
autour de nous on pardonnez moi ce que
je voulais juste dire c'est que il ya
évidemment ce que la loi peut permettre
il ya ce que la loi doit faire notamment
en matière de contrôle mais nous avons
aussi chrome messieurs veulent un choix
qui est un problème de micro alors que
je courais ce que je dois passer mon
micro à monsieur belin présente assez
bon c'est bien ce que je disais à
l'instant c'est quand est ce que la loi
peut permettre il ya ce que la loi en
particulier doit mettre en oeuvre
notamment en matière de contrôle de
respect des contrats c'est un point très
important mais il faut aussi en même
temps que dans nos filières dans la
relation contractuelle qui s'établit on
est aussi une capacité de jouer un peu
plus sa transparence
un peu plus sa confiance ok alors une
petite pause parce qu'il ya des
manifestants lara qui est qui qui qui
vous interpellent jeu le jeu les criques
j'ai cru comprendre puisque je vois des
slogans contre les ogm on vous entendu
on vous entendu messieurs
la question sera posée à monsieur belin
qui effectivement a tenu des propos qui
n'ont pas dans votre sens sur ce sujet
mais on y reviendra alors la suite de
notre reversé sur rester sur la question
des prix il faut dire que là les
négociateurs de la distribution ils sont
bien aidés par l'effondrement des cours
mondiaux
oui quand on est sorti des quotas
l'année dernière au mois de mars
on n'a pas entendu le monde agricole
s'inquiéter de cette sortie de quotas ah
bon qui avait été négociée bien en avant
on était plutôt sûr on veut augmenter la
production on va miser sur l'exportation
sinon je suis comme paris non je suis
pas tout à fait d'accord et goose que je
reconnais c'est la france a été isolé au
moment de la discussion sur la sortie
des quotas nous étions nous demandeurs
de maintenir un système alors peut-être
pas de quotas mais de maîtrise de la
production
parce que nous craignons ce qui arrive
en ce moment faut bien voir que quand je
regarde sur un an à peine un an
d'ailleurs avril à décembre 2015
fin des quotas en avril des pays ont
augmenté leur production de 4 à 10% et
pas des moins les pays-bas l'allemagne
l'irlande et c est pourquoi la france
n'arrive pas en ce cas là mais c'est pas
que la france est il passé sur terre non
mais la france a une certaine idée de la
maîtrise de la production
on a progressé de 1% on est même en
dessous des autorisations de quotas
qu'ils étaient permises avant avril 2015
je pense que la france ne peut pas être
accusé aujourd'hui des tensions
production je vous donne un autre
paramètre intéressant
quinze ans en arrière la production de
porcs allemagne france espagne 25
millions de cochons produit chaque année
en 2000 en 2015 15 ans après on est à 21
millions en france 40 en allemagne 46 en
espagne
donc cessons aussi de dire que la france
ne fait pas son travail
une certaine maîtrise d'une certaine
rien que la la france est la première
puissance agricole dernières
statistiques eurostat 18% à elle seule
chute de la production européenne
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle n'a l'impression
que le marasme
le malaise n'a lieu qu ici pourquoi
est-ce qu'on n'a pas l'impression que
les paysans soient si mal parce qu'en
valeur relative
un certain nombre de nos collègues
aujourd'hui c'est vrai sur l'allemagne
mais c'est vrai aussi sur les pays
d'europe réoriente d'europe centrale et
orientale
c'est vrai pour l'espagne ont une
attitude beaucoup plus conquérant et
d'ailleurs viennent nous prendre des
parts de marché sur notre propre marché
alors il s'agit pas de dire il faut
produire plus il s'agit simplement de
dire est-ce que sur un marché européen
28 est ce qu'on peut se doter d'un
certain nombre et d'un minimum de moyens
de régulation de la production ou alors
ça veut dire qu'on organise à
l'intérieur même des frontières
européennes
une espèce de concurrence exacerbée ou
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
les plus faibles tomberont je crois
qu'on n'a pas intérêt à ça aujourd'hui
concurrence avec les voisins immédiats
l'allemagne et l'espagne avec des
ouvriers payés à 3 euros de l'heure est
ce que c'est quelque chose
d'irréversible
on a assisté à la fin de la sidérurgie à
la fin du textile en france
est ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui la fin de
l'élevage non bien sûr que non et
surtout pas parce que d'ailleurs ne
soyons pas paradoxaux contradictoire
quand le ministre a fait sa loi d'avenir
il a voulu mettre en avant justement
sinon un réquilibrage en tout cas un
équilibre durable entre végétales et
animales
là dessus nous suivons mais encore
faut-il quand même que les productions
animales puisse aussi trouvé leur leur
propre comment dire leur propre
environnement économique pour pouvoir
perdurer
je prends un seul exemple en production
laitière aujourd'hui
bien sûr on parle du grand wez mais je
vais prendre une autre région qu'est la
lorraine où le laisse de la france des
systèmes mixtes végétal animal sur la
même exploitation
si le prix du lait durablement ne permet
plus de rentabiliser le travail de
l'éleveur
que croyez-vous qu'il arrive ça voudra
dire qu on abandonnera l'élevage laitier
au profit de cultures céréalières c'est
pas souhaitable en termes les clips
c'est pas ce talent non plus en termes
d'éco système tout simplement vous
parliez vous même d'écosystèmes et de
paysages mais même audace hors
d'équilibré jettent à l'animal est ce
que vous avez des chiffres concernant
justement les conversions les éleveurs
qui ont abandonné l'élevage ou bien
simplement qu'ils se sont retirés qui
ont jeté les planches non j'ai papier
peut pas s'y met on en a tous les jours
et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui nous rend
fébrile parce que malheureusement là où
il ya une densité d'élevage
ça veut dire qu'on a les infrastructures
autour avec du ramassage de la collecte
des laiteries des ateliers de l'abattage
découpe en porc ou en viande bovine là
dessus ça ça fonctionne là où il ya une
densité plus faible
imaginez que 10 15 % des éleveurs se
disent terminée moi je bute sur un autre
système
est ce que ces entreprises de l'aval de
la production pourront perdurer
la réponse est non voilà il ya tout un
équilibre économique social and
ecosystem à respecter une dernière
question
une dernière question qui est toujours à
vendre aborder avec beaucoup de pudeur
des timidités même par le monde agricole
concernant les suicides les dernières
statistiques officielles dont on dispose
qui remonte à 2013 disait qu'entre 2008
et 2013 on avait un suicides
d'agriculteurs tous les deux jours
est-ce que vous avez des remontées du
terrain aujourd'hui pour vous dire où on
en est en particulier dans l'ouest où on
est confronté à la fois crise du lait et
du porc
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de pudeur
en parler parce que c'est un sujet
difficile et délicat les chiffres
aujourd'hui alors il faut les prendre
aussi en prenant s'il ya parfois
d'autres causes que la seule pause
économie il yal isolement il peut y
avoir des points de familiaux fin mais
tout ça se cumulent un quelque part
et c'est vrai qu'on est plus proche
malheureusement d'un
d'un acte fatal pratiquement chaque jour
aujourd'hui en france pourrait
simplement dire que dans chaque
département maintenant nous avons des
cellules d'accompagnement des
agriculteurs en difficulté qui combine à
la fois des approches par des
travailleurs sociaux des psychologues
mais aussi un accompagnement social et
économie et je demande pour ma part j'ai
pas si on pourra loger sa dans cette
fameuse loi sapin 2 mais je demande qu
enfin nous ayons un vrai statut
d'agriculteur pour protéger ne serait ce
que le patrimoine personnel et privé de
l'agriculteur ce que lorsqu'il ya dépôt
de bilan et malheureusement ça va
jusqu'à la liquidation
tout y passe nous sommes un des rares
secteurs à vivre cette situation
photo co protège l'agriculteur et sa
famille
l'outil de travail c'est l'outil de
travail on peut avoir droit à l'échec
on peut avoir pour des tas de raisons
exogènes très souvent plus endogène la
possibilité aussi de déposer un bilan
n'avait culture merci anne chaon
troisième partie de l'émission donc vous
allez pouvoir répondre à vos détracteurs
xavier beulin il y en a dans
l'assistance on les a entendu un peu
bruyamment tout à l'heure j'ai vu des
panneaux dénonçant
les pesticides dont vous seriez donc un
tenant et puis également le recours aux
ogm c'est vrai que vous les défendez
d'une certaine manière mais les prises
de position se sont multipliés ces
derniers jours notamment depuis le début
du salon d'aviculture
alors donc la troisième partie est
simple a accusé xavier beulin répondez à
vos critiques
que dites vous à vos détracteurs
nombreux par exemple jean luc mélenchon
et nicolas dupont aignan
ce qui est en impasse c'est tout ce
modèle agricole et les gens non ne
peuvent pas se faire entendre
vous avez vu le ministre de
l'agriculture lui il respecte les
traités européens
ce sont les traités européens qui ont
conduit à cette situation ensuite il est
flanqué de monsieur xavier beulin qu'est
le problème numéro un de l'agriculture
française à la tête de son syndicat
parce que ils représentent ce qui n'est
plus vraiment de la paysannerie
mais une espèce de aux industries liées
à la finance et aux grandes transactions
internationales dollars c'est le
pyromane qui fait semblant d'être
pompier
il a trahi les agriculteurs il ne défend
pas les quotas laitiers défend pas un
prix garanti
il est dans le conflit d'intérêt
permanent
c'est un conflit d'intérêt il est plus
industrielles que paysans alors mais
qu'est la messe nous ont rejoints
sa mission sacrée les voleurs qu'est ce
que vous répondez à nicolas dupont
aignan commentaire aucun commentaire
vous êtes interpellé vous lancez pas
être interpellé ça c'est de l'invectivé
personnel pour se faire plaisir sur un
plateau devant un micro ça n'appelle
aucun commentaire aucune raison rake en
jeu le jour le jour où ces messieurs
auront le courage d'aborder les
questions de fond je viendrai débattent
avec eux pas sur ces sujets là parce que
vous en faut du courage vous pour
répondre à toutes ces critiques à ce
sont les journées comme sûr j'en ai je
suis combatif mais pas sur ce type de
propos est-ce que je vais m'occuper mois
de la mine de monsieur mélenchon ça ne
m'intéresse pas
qu'ils viennent débattre des vrais
sujets quand il me dit aujourd'hui par
exemple on s'occupe pas des points de
l'agriculture on oublie les prix
garantis
on était content on était pour les
quotas laitiers m'enfin où vont ils
chercher ces informations mais c'est du
populisme à l'état pur alors il ya une
personne qui a fait irruption sur ce
plateau enfin on vous invite madame
bonjour
on vous donne la parole à urt à une
condition c'est que vous acceptez quand
même que nous restions ici les maîtres
du jeu
nous allons continuer notre émission
comme prévu avec monsieur gaulin nous
avons également nos questions à lui
poser vous savez elles ne sont pas
toutes en dhr vous êtes intervenu avec
des hauts cris qu'est ce que vous avez
envie de dire à monsieur paulin qui est
là et vous répondra et tout retournerait
dans le public bien que tu es on est
venu dire que nous on descend d une
autre agriculture qui qu'une agriculture
qui respecte le vivant je pense qu'on a
oublié que la terre c'était du vivant
que les agriculteurs sont des êtres
humains les animaux sont des êtres
humains que les semences c'est aussi de
la végétation vivante et que le
consommateur il a droit à mieux que le
système agricole actuel qu'on défend et
que monsieur xavier beulin défense et
pas le nôtre
c'est un système qui va à sa perte qui
produit mâle qui détruit nos
agriculteurs et vous même mais vous vous
avez vous vous exprimez euros à quel
titre vous personnellement on en est
faux cheikh volontaire aujourd'hui on
est venu dénoncer les agrocarburants qui
nous ponctionne encore des terres et qui
cultive en pente des ogm cachés qui sont
faits pour résister à des pesticides qui
sont les ogm tournesol et colza mutés
qui a été exclu de la réglementation
mais qui sont quand même les ogm en
temps au terme scientifique du terme
quoi bon maintenant vous êtes prête à
écouter la réponse de monsieur poulin je
les écoute volontiers
eh bien il vous répond merci madame
voilà mes valeurs
madame qu'est ce que je peux répondre à
madame d'abord je suis d'accord avec
elle que l'agriculteur sa première
fonction c'est travailler que le vivant
et la suite je suis complètement en
phase le vivant pardonnez moi
l'expression on en vit tous les jours
quand on est paysan
maintenant je veux rétablir 2,3 vérité
un aucune culture des ogm en france
aucune 2 nous consommons tous les jours
tous les jours en france et en europe
des ogm que l'on importe massivement ça
ne dérange personne on le sait par
personne et par an baissant le savait
mais bien sûr on ne cesse de leurs plus
bas mais surtout les donc micro et que
les surfaces des armadas je vous ai
écoutés laissez moi vos réponses et
c'est monsieur bell a répondu oui
non mais allez madame comtesse je peux
vous donner les chiffres 45 millions de
tonnes 35 de soja 10 de maïs et autres
productions d'un grand dans l'union
européenne si les ogm par exemple et
c'est une vérité est ce que ça nous gêne
d'apporter ses productions
réponse ne mélangeons pas tout les
sujets en matière d'innovation et en
particulier de technologie et je suis
navré de dire à cette dame que par
ailleurs je respecte je suis navré dû
dire qu'aujourd'hui une des réponses de
l'agriculture pour la france sera
évidemment l'innovation pourquoi parce
qu'on le voit bien tous les jours par la
semence par les technologies du
numérique par l'informatique embarquée
bref par un certain nombre de
technologies aujourd'hui pour la
robotisation nous ferons de la culture
française à nouveau un pôle d'excellence
ne nous trompons pas de combat et je
voudrais enfin quatrième sujet d'hier à
7,1 oui et je peux pas être content
défaut là dessus que la fnsea depuis
toujours défend toutes les agricultures
c'est pas une contre l'autre mais
cessons d'opposer ces agricultures
moi je suis très fier aujourd'hui quand
je vais dans tel et tel territoire de
pouvoir consommer des produits terroir
et de dire ça c'est l'excellence
française mais je suis tout aussi fier
quand je vais à l'étranger et je trouve
un certain nombre de produits qui ont
été exportés par les paysans français
qui font aussi notre fierté
n'opposons pas toutes les agricultures
de grâce vous avez besoin vous êtes
interpellé un petit peu partout et même
applaudi de temps en temps la playbook
est ce que c'est pour vous le salon le
plus difficile que vous ayez eu à
connaître c'est pas pour moi la
difficulté à la dre personnel quand même
mais pas du tout la difficulté
aujourd'hui aller où j'avais prévenu
présent la république avant qu'ils
rentrent dans le salon payer les allées
sont très fraîches cette année je suis
pas trompé et rock très froid pour ré
froide
bon pourquoi parce que la crise elle est
profonde elle est durable
aujourd'hui on peut pas dire un
aviculteur continue à faire de la
qualité on va te mettre des cahiers des
charges
on va déposer des réglementations le
prix à non ça on n'en parle pas ça n'est
plus tenable sur le social élections ça
ne tient pas vous attendez moi ces
poèmes nomel pointe de bellaing il est
pas là si demain mes collègues de la fsu
estime qu'ils sont mal défendu change de
président donc c'est un faux problème
il ya zéro difficulté par rapport à ça
le combat n'est certain
malgré ça dans un maintenant est ce que
vous serez candidat remettez mois dans
la question se pose pas pas encore non
les permettez-moi de rajouter un mot un
seul je suis accusée aussi aujourd'hui
de porter la responsabilité d'un groupe
agroalimentaire
je n'en suis pas le président exécutif
j'en suis le président au nom des
paysans qui sont majoritairement
actionnaires de ce groupe pourquoi parce
que ces mêmes paysans il ya trente ans
on fait un constat si on n'investit pas
sur la transformation sur la valeur
ajoutée de nos produits nous
n'existerons plus dans 30 ans quand vous
assumer tout ce que vous êtes
aujourd'hui ce gros il fonctionne il
permet à des tas de filières d'avoir des
débouchés oui il ya aussi une partie de
biochimie de biocarburants et c'est ça
qui vous est alors j'ai là qui m'est
reproché au nom de quoi
aujourd'hui tout le monde se gargarise
avec la terre on aura compris
avec comme 21 en parlant du renouvelable
sur tous les tons le renouvelable sais
quoi dans l'agriculture dans la forêt
c'est de la biomasse à disposition d'un
certain nombre d'utilisations voilà sur
quoi nous travaillons est alors y at il
un crime aujourd'hui il n'y a pas à
consacrer selon vous mais il n'y a aucun
conflit d'intérêts défendent des plus
peu de moi j'aimerais chez moi ici qu'à
la place de ces dames il ya un
producteurs de colza ou tournesol qui
viennent dire grâce à avril grâce à la
filière oléoprotéagineuse je vends mes
graines un peu mieux que le marché
mondial
et s'il était là il viendrait le dire
parce que voilà ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
alors voilà je veux pas nous ne sommes
pas des manifestants nous ne sommes pas
des peintures est temps de recoller et
absolument et on vous donne l'occasion
de vous défendre
ça va continuer parce qu'on va écouter
le porte parole de europe ecologie les
verts rabah décidément qui vous
critiquez vous répondez à l'est on
passera à autre chose
vous aviez blanc c'est une arnaque parce
qu'en fait c'est un grand industriel
cette l'agrobusiness 2 avril sofiprotéol
c'est pas du tout le représentant des
petits des petits éleveurs pas du tout
et même ses intérêts sont opposés c'est
à dire que quand nous les écologistes
ont dit on veut sauver l'agriculture on
veut sauver le paysan dans la campagne
qui est utile aux territoires qui est
nourri ses bêtes et qui rend les élèves
or de la maltraitance et sans pesticides
et sans ce que vous voulez là on est
dans le soutien à l'agriculture durable
quand vous avez xavier beulin qui
demande en gros des baisses de
cotisations pour pouvoir développer
toujours plus eh bien il condamne à
terme
l'agriculture française un procureur
alors qu'est ce qu'ils ont envie d'aller
formidable comment est ce que vous
pouvez vous tous les gens qui viennent
s'exprimer et de mélenchon à ce monsieur
que je ne connais pas parce que j'aime
bien les accusations mais enfin tu en
entends geremek certains d'entre eux
viennent me parler directement
plutôt que de parler par caméras
interposées qu'est ce que vous laissez
les gens ils disent quoi ils disent
aujourd'hui barricadons nous fermons les
frontières françaises
faisons une petite agriculture et tout
ira bien ils sont en train de condamner
non pas quelques centaines de milliers
d'agriculteurs ils sont en train de
condamner des millions d'emplois qui
c'est autour de ce plateau combien
génère d'emplois l'agriculture française
est hors agriculteurs nous avons un
million cinq cent mille ans d'accord
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est l'insee
bon est-ce qu'on veut détruire tout ça
oui il ya moins d'agriculteurs qui a 30
ans mais savez vous que depuis trente
ans la sphère agricole n'a pas perdu un
seul emploi il ya eu des transferts ya
moins à la production il ya beaucoup
plus en amont en aval et dans les
services rattachés agriculture c'est ça
la rennaise que vous avez l'impression
parfois de faire un front un certain
obscurantisme la revue du problème
furent bien sûr oui oui ou alors ne
m'attendais de deux choses l'une soit
nous dit on
nous nions tout ce qui a été fait tout
ce qui a été signé comme accords
internationaux depuis 20 ou 30 ans à
l'om c'est les traités européens
et dans ce cas là ok je suis la
démonstration ou alors nous prenons at
la saturn ou d'orientation politique
je ne vois pas aujourd'hui y compris les
fissures en europe à remettre en cause
l'ensemble de ces dispositions
et dans ce cas là ça veut dire que je
mesure demain un producteur néerlandais
un producteur polonais un producteur
allemand mais aussi un producteur
américain canadien argentin et c est ce
qu'on est capable d'accepter ça quelque
part
au revoir aussi le modèle de
l'agriculture française on a une
division comme jamais du monde agricole
aujourd'hui avec cette crise est ce que
c'est quelque chose que vous pouvez
imaginer aujourd'hui revoir tout cela
tout remettre sur la table vaut dix
jours que religions du monde agricole
ouais y'a pas de division du monde
agricole
quentin gallet juridique on voit les
manifestations allaient bien mais qu'est
ce qu'ils expriment ces agriculteurs ils
expriment leur détresse leur colère leur
désarroi ils pensent à leurs familles
qui sont derrière moi que je suis j'ai
les larmes quand un jeune vient me dire
j'ai 30 ans je tire pas de salaire j'ai
deux enfants
c'est mon épouse parce que je les
envoyais travailler à l'extérieur qui
fait nourrir là qui fait mourir la la
marmite enfin est-ce qu'on peut accepter
ça c'est pas possible d'entendre ça donc
moi je me bats pour quoi pour qui la
dignité pour qui est vraiment une
dimension humaine et sociale derrière le
métier d'agriculteur mais ça se fera pas
comme sa part de l'incantation ça se
fera parce que derrière
oui on aura des filières solide oui on
aura des prix qui permettront de
rémunérer et will surtout on reconnaîtra
enfin que dans cette chaîne alimentaire
le paysan c'est pas la variable
d'ajustement c'est par lui que devrait
commencer la construction des prix et
pas par lui que ça devrait finir on a
parlé des normes que vous combattrez à
doper de but de cette émission fait d'un
fonds notamment inspiré par le grenelle
de l'environnement et le principe de
promotion ouais il s'impose aussi dans
les recherches wings cultuelle ou demain
vous le reconnaissez est-ce qu'il ya
deux attitudes possibles il fait grossir
oui ou bien on traite leur confiance ou
pas non mais où on traite tout ça par la
réglementation excessive par la
coercition par une sur l'administration
permanente où on traite ça aussi par de
l'innovation part de leurs recherches
par de vraies alternatives
ces nouveaux appareils censés que les
paysans français maths le français le
matin solaire en se disant tiens
aujourd'hui je vais aller pondre un peu
dépôt de phytosanitaires sur mes
parcelles
j'aime faire plaisir enfin on est tombé
sur la tête de nos contemporains sont
les premières vivent bon c'est
aujourd'hui ya en face ici à l'inra des
tas d'innovations extrêmement concret
les drones tout ce qui va nous permettre
demain de faire des interventions
sectorielles sur nos parcelles
intervenir auprès de nos animaux pour
traiter le problème est pas traiter de
manière préventive et curative
tout ça c'est des progrès fantastiques
prenons tout ça en compte
c'est comme ça qu'on va gagner la partie
c'est pas en étant dans des postures
rétrograde de la posture si vous le
voulez bien sur un plan peut-être plus
personnel quels contacts vous gardez
vous aujourd'hui avec la terre vous avez
dit tout à l'heure que vous étiez mais
je suis paysan cher monsieur vous êtes
paysan vous la fia sur les gens enfin si
mais trois associés si mes trois
associés étaient là ils vous diraient
que le week-end je suis q sur le
tracteur ou chez au niveau des de la
traite ou des who delà du soin des
animaux
c'est ça mon boulot la semaine louis on
peut me reprocher d'être à paris d'être
à bruxelles d'état berlin dette
oui peut-être là aussi la légende dit
que vos détracteurs mettent sur la table
en disant que finalement vous avez des
joueurs castrais temps d'enlever une
aussi mais c'est tellement facile tout
ça fasse ça ne m'intéresse pas vraiment
bon et puis la vie d'un syndicat il
savait c'est très éphémère lorsque c'est
usant et puis à 5 heures du matin à
minuit tous les jours et bien parce que
s'il ya des gens qui vous crie un moment
vraiment autre chose
il ya peut-être aussi des gens qui vous
critiquent même en interne elle a été
déçue et je pense qu'on en entend des
choses ici aller les chercher
faites-les témoigner est peut-être passé
près n'ont ainsi pas forcément devant
une caméra ou façades et on peut dire
tout ce qu'on veut
la fse c'est une organisation on ne peut
plus démocratique sa part de la commune
jusqu'à paris bon
citez moi une autre organisation qui
soit aussi démocratique bon moi je suis
représentatif des paysans français qui
monte lui le reste c'est du verbiage
c'est du fantasme
vous avez vous avez voulu vous pour
mieux vous comprendre peut-être est-ce
que vous êtes un syndicaliste plus
proche d'un pierre gattaz pour les
grands patrons plus proche d'un philippe
martinez pour la cgt vous vous situez où
en quoi ça fait réagir au mois ça fait
réagir
vous vous situez ou alors la question
appelle une réponse est non et xavier
beulin j'ai 57 ans je suis paysan dans
le loiret j'ai trois associés et je fais
du syndicaliste depuis l'âge de 22 23
ans et j'ai commencé mon métier à 17 ans
donc ceux qui rêvent ou ceux qui pensent
que bellaing c'est le type qui a fait
chez pas quoi qui a fait tels étaient
les grandes écoles non je n'ai qu'un
seul diplôme c'est mon permis de
conduire et mon permis moto auquel je
suis très fier et le reste ça c'est
votre boulot à côté opéré d'une rupture
ton me traite
j'ai au moins j'ai au moins une fierté
que j'ai au moins une pierre mais j'ai
au moins une fierté je n'en parle jamais
mais puisque vous me poussée dans mes
retranchements je vais en parler pour la
première fois j'ai pris l'exploitation à
l'âge de 17 ans
mon père décède un soir le lendemain
matin je suis paysan à 5 heures du matin
j'arrête les cours j'ai trois frères et
soeurs derrière moi j'ai une belle et
puis voilà les choses se passent comme
ça donc le reste vous savez moi les
donneurs de leçons
j'ai l'est où ils sont et je ne veux pas
répondre à certaines attaques
je trouve cet affligeant je vais pas
savoir mais si monsieur mélenchon
monsieur dupont-aignan monsieur
tartempion ap tel et tel parcours
au moins vous pouvez répondre
aujourd'hui à toutes et à tous les
détracteurs
absolument c'est aussi pour cela qu'on
vous invité inattendu merci
et vous êtes venu avec nos supporters
alors là non
alors les missions et comment je voyais
l'agriculture à l'échéance de 50 ans
pardon à l'échéance de 50 ans comment
est ce que vous voyez vous comment
est-ce que vous rêvez c'est ça notre
dernière question comment est ce que
vous arrivez l'agriculture française moi
j'ai mal aux tripes quand je vois la
culture française qui régresse j'ai mal
aux tripes
on a un potentiel formidable dans ce
pays le premier d'entre eux c'est le
potentiel humain fantastique un savoir
faire exceptionnel des produits
d'excellence une diversité agricole un
climat des terres on a tout ce qu'il
faut
comment se fait-il comment se fait-il
comment se fait-il qu'aujourd'hui on ne
soit pas en capacité d'assumer d'
assumer politiquement socialement
sociologiquement un pôle agricole un
pôle alimentaire qui devrait être dit
sont dans ce pays
parler d'agriculture aujourd'hui c'est
la maladie honteuse enfin quand même
est-ce qu'on peut un peu se reprendre et
se dire qu'enfin on est capable de se
promouvoir non seulement pour mouvoir
mais d'accompagner cette promotion avec
quelques mesures clés redonner confiance
permettent l'investissement permettent
l'innovation rayonner sur les marchés
satisfait en aux consommateurs c'est ça
notre projet moi j'en ai pas d'autre
le reste ne m'intéresse pas l'intérêt
général avant tout mon intérêt personnel
vous savez à l'âge où j'ai il est
derrière moi donc c'est fini
merci
merci xavier collin d'avoir répondu à
toutes ses questions dans de cette
émission
même les questions qui fâchent certains
mais vous y avez répondu avec beaucoup
de courage et détermination merci à vous
et à très bientôt